[Music]
I'm Imran Khan Elijah's there is
correspondent hearing back there a
larger space piece tremendously hard
battling with ISIL fighters in Anbar
province in Ramadi and in Fallujah
vivace army has faced a number of
casualties
I thought have made inland attacks on
Iraqi army combat soldiers directly ISIL
fighters are in large parts of the
country but in Ramadi is illusia they
have been in control of huge chunks of
both of the cities the reason being is
because there is a tremendous
dissatisfaction with the sheer lead
government here I saw are some new
fighters and they say there's the Shilla
command here is basically cracking down
on something that has resonated with
anti-government tribal sheiks they've
got a lot of support on the ground here
in the funny neighborhoods that they've
been into we have to remember ISIL is
the Islamic State of Iraq and the Levant
they fight in Syria and in Iraq it
really comes to the force and the
situation in Syria has deteriorated
they've been able to bring bring in
foreign fighters into Iraq they've been
able to quell their numbers
significantly there is a source of
funding money weapons coming into them
the Iraqi government has asked militia
groups to arm and to go and take the
fight to ISIL how do you control those
militia groups proneness the Nouri
al-maliki's asking for a state of
emergency to be declared that
effectively means all the power put into
his hands the last time that happened
there are some of the controls the time
we think
you